who was the comedian that inspired you
to go into comedy was there one
sam kinnison when i when i started com
comedy my first year
sam kinnison came to uh where i lived in
ottawa canada
he was the best he was a [ __ ] great
he really he couldn't get work in the
states you know because he'd walk rooms
and i [ __ ] saw him that's the amazing
thing just every night
why couldn't he get work in the states
because he'd walk every room you know
what does that mean walk everywhere like
everybody would walk out oh i should
when i thought about it later man like
you know these guys think they're all
[ __ ] uh
uh whatever you're called what are you
calling edgy
edgy all this [ __ ] all they're doing is
swearing and doing this
but [ __ ] kennison man in a room full
of
and he was unknown in a room full of
everybody's on a date
he would [ __ ] go up to them and go
don't [ __ ] get married
[ __ ] it's the worst [ __ ] thing yeah
right and people would [ __ ] go holy
[ __ ] i'm with this woman you know
don't tell me your problems yeah and you
challenge him so much but he wasn't a
jokey kind of guy right you don't like a
guy who does schticky joke after joke
after job i like
there's very few that i like but i love
ronnie dangerfield as my favorite
and then he was a guy who would fire off
jokes but he was jokes out to be so
[ __ ] good did he write his own jokes
yeah he wrote them all
i know guys who went into meetings with
him about a movie
yeah yeah he'd show up late in a
bathrobe with his balls hanging out
and like legendary stories you talk
about not giving a [ __ ]
you worship that you don't you want to
be that guy who doesn't give a [ __ ]
right
i met rodney man when i was [ __ ] i
made the worst mistake ever
which i was in the [ __ ] hotel and i
loved running [ __ ] i didn't know him
and i was coming down in the in the
casino i was coming down the
the [ __ ] elevator and rodney was in
the elevator i'm like oh my god it's
rodney i got to say something to him so
anyways i'd worked on some stupid
[ __ ] thing with this
director yeah who said he worked with
rodney yeah
so i used that as a thing right so i go
hey rodney i go we have a common friend
he goes who's that i go you know
paul johnson he goes that [ __ ] sucker
because that [ __ ] has no friend and
there's a full elevator that [ __ ] is no
friend of mine you tell him he can suck
my dick i'm like oh
i'm not his friend i'm not his friend
you know you hear these stories that
rodney was sort of a bitter guy because
he made it late in life and all that but
yet he was a sweet guy because he helped
i mean he did something for me that i'll
never forget like i
i appeared on the tonight show with jay
leno and uh rodney called me at my house
now i didn't know rodney he just said
hey
how are the i just want to tell you you
know when i used to do shows no one ever
called me no one no one ever said i did
good
i knew what you were doing up there you
were great you were doing a great job
and
i was like wow rodney danger i mean
because he's the guy you know
he thinks he did okay i must have done
okay
so what a tremendous nice thing to do
for something unbelievable
i met him i was on saturday live when i
did update he he came and did some jokes
on his 75th birthday
so we have to do dress first at 8 30 and
then at 11 30 of the show you know
right so he comes and he's like hey you
know i gotta [ __ ] talk to you you
know so i can win
and i'm like mr dangerfield it's great
to me and the first time i ever met him
he goes listen man he goes what the [ __ ]
man why am i doing it at 8 30. you know
it's the same thing i know my [ __ ]
jokes i'll just come back at 11 30.
i go i don't know how it works rodney
you got to do it he goes god damn
he goes let me tell you something kid
this was a device kid because let me
tell you something kid he goes this
[ __ ] tv [ __ ] you know
he goes just waiting around all the
[ __ ] time it's a bunch of saw [ __ ]
you know it's [ __ ]
because it's the same with [ __ ]
movies you know you're in the movie and
then you're in the [ __ ] trailer all
the time that's all you're doing you're
[ __ ]
jerking off in the trailer you know
because it's all [ __ ] giddy because
remember this and remember it remember
it forever stand up man that's all there
is stand up
and he meant it then there's a [ __ ]
like five minute pause he look at me
right in the eyes he goes stand up [ __ ]
he forgot it's all [ __ ]
a negative guy yeah it's just great
though what a funny man just
naturally funny man